roxanna's in tampa
hey roxanne how are you hey guys thanks
for taking my call
um i am about a month into ramsey plus
i'm loving it
good and um i have
called today because i also as you
advised me to do i got rid of my very
expensive car and i bought a six
thousand dollar
beautiful car nice good for you
so and it's paid off which i love so um
my next question though is
i have a lot of student loans and i'm a
public educator so
i have the public service loan
forgiveness
which is a program where if you pay for
10 years
you get the rest of your loans forgiven
no you don't
it was a scam have you not have you not
read the articles
95 000 people have applied for it
after their 10 years of service 18
people have had their loans forgiven
everyone else was denied
oh wow no it's not they didn't do it
they scammed you so there are some there
are some loan forgiveness programs that
are real
that one is not has not worked out and i
would not wait 10 years
and hope that the government keeps its
word because they haven't
okay i would just get the loan so that
was my question
my question was do i wait wait it out or
do i
put it into my debt snowball so that
snowball and get rid of it how much debt
have you got
it's about two hundred thousand dollars
oh man
oh my goodness what what grade do you
teach
um i'm in a k-8 school i'm an assistant
principal
oh okay okay good and are you single or
married
single and what do you what what's your
what's your income
my income is about 63.
how long have you been an assistant
principal
uh for about 12 years okay
uh it's going to take you a while um
i hope it doesn't take you 10 years uh
but that's
um that is a small shovel in a big hole
and so you may you may be starting a
tutoring business on the side to get
some income
coming in and try to double your income
over a period of time here so that you
can attack this at a faster rate
but the um your return on investment two
hundred thousand invested to get a sixty
three 000
job was horrible uh it was a horrible
return for you
i'm sorry for that i'm glad that you're
there and i'm glad you're an assistant
principal and i'm glad that people like
you
are serving i'm very sorry that you're
that far in debt to get
into that to get that kind of an income
um
i mean so my goodness yeah it's going to
take you a little while kiddo but i
i would not be waiting on the government
to do it
i'm going to just start chipping away at
it and figuring out what i can do to get
my income
up and attack it as fast as you can
that's distressing well it's so hard
when these
i mean you get these numbers like that
and sadly they're
they're more common than not these days
i mean like that upwards of six figures
people
it's the reality and so that it just
takes
it's going to take a lot 250 000
and then they're an md it's making 150
200 a year
um and it's just oh
so if guys if you guys have not um
listened to the eight
episode series called borrowed future
that uh the podcast that the ramsey
networks did
you guys need to go listen to it and um
so you understand how bad the student
loan
program is you've you know
we the people it has destroyed people's
lives
and um we the people are doing this to
ourselves
and uh you and i are guaranteeing these
loans because we're taxpayers
and and so um and we're putting people
in it like her in bondage
uh allowing her to do that to herself
and oh i'm so sorry what a horrible i'm
so sad
um but yeah that and this is why the
student loan program has to be stopped
it's not working it has to be stopped
it's out of control
it's an epic failure
and so um it's just um
i mean she she's going to be scratching
and glowing for a while